virginie vous avez cette fois là je vais
faire je vous tester voilà les i c'est
quoi le test c'est l'interview psy c'est
hiriart buisson est capable d'expliquer
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle non
c'est guy bedos
bon alors allons-y c'est tout simplement
si tu n'as tu as loupé si c'est pour
savoir quel est votre état de ces chics
après une seule jambe un seigneur parce
que c'est un peu plus intimes comme ça
pour savoir quel est votre état
psychique après une semaine de promotion
sur la plage
est ce que vous êtes dépressives ou je
vous êtes névrosé ou coup de c0 défaut
c'est-à-dire c-zéro desservi par un an
ça m'arrive dans quelles circonstances
plusieurs camps votre jules tourner avec
leonardo dicaprio doute un peu mais je
vis très mal joué excuses au nom et la
call girl et si nous pouvons quand même
cela nous a tous l'histoire est ce que
vous êtes exhibo annonce à 10 avec fu
médias chez actrice donc mais un pnj
vous retourner à expulser en même temps
ça fait cher andré xivo mais je pense
pas que ça je dis comme je me dis je ce
gir 2 dijon a dit exit binationaux à cet
ebook djibo on dit exito exhibe y exhibe
lycée quand on est vieux
est ce que vous êtes alors ça c'est très
drôle
est ce que vous êtes porno fob c'est ce
que sepang malaisie mais je ne suis pas
ne pas supporter le porno c'est la
première que je vois qu'ils connaissent
a dit persuadé qu nous quoi
mais attendez vous trouvez là parce que
c'est du grec ancien vous allez voir
c'est du grec ancien et les voir je vous
êtes ado je n'arrivais à 1 une petite
perversion est ce que vous êtes sac à
dos premier défaut le tatouage est ce
que vous êtes en asie où virginie
ledoyen père quand c'est minime 0 nous
agirons tôt à un peu quand même dit la
vérité la réponse ou passants ne pouvais
pas me mentir c'est quoi dire honte j'ai
honte on voit là bas elle aime les gens
un peu plus âgé qu'elle et virginie a
bien été recadrée elle aime bien avoir
des gens elle a bien être avec des
hommes un peu plus c'est sexuel géronto
c'est à dire que l'attirance
gérontophilie c'est la france qu'on a
pour des gens un peu plus âgées les
jeunes qui par là tu te ridiculises chez
jvc la dernière fois qu'ils nous
inviterons à dîner une édition sont
gentils les religions sont gentils
fétichiste non voyeuriste huit mois
d'été pour moi j'aime pas ce qu'est ce
que permet à ce palais de fabrication
perversion mais sinon plein mais
heureusement les actrices nous allons
enfin là il faut bien compter les
agoraphones n'aime pas la foule
ah je croyais elle avait peur des
araignées au venin qui est dû aux liens
que vous pouvez trouver ça est ce que
vous êtes canaux fob à je sais en plus
elle ne sait quoi qu'il nous fallait la
peur du mari de barbie
ouais
boivin
gp du grec ancien club quel onze ans que
notre accès celle qui a peur de
l'obscurité
moi je connais sa nuit fob justement
est-ce que vous êtes nikto fob nungesser
mais ces masques en croit sérieux
sérieux nique nique ta la nuit voilà ces
gens cassent pas la nuit
est ce que vous êtes et lourau fob
finlande city sait pas par contre j'ai
raté là on ne s'y trompent pas et
n'auront pas fait car c'est ce que ces
maximes et l'europhobe ces gens qui ont
peur des chats est ce que vous êtes
sinophobe maxi et maxi 1000 et pas
sinophobe dans la belle somme ils sont
pas si nos amis cynophiles
ils sont cynophiles on s'est compris de
complicité entre ben y'a un truc
s'arrête pas là je vous montre que tu
pourrais écrire un cv c'est le plus dur
est ce que vous êtes aérodrome aux
folles 3 la bâche génial mes repères
tout le monde croit que c'est la peur
des aérodromes
non non c'est la peur dans les aéroports
c'est la peur des à durban au parloir
l'espagne on est là mais dit sauf il se
fit attendre trois personnes
est ce que vous êtes sidero de romo fob
je suis rhône et non la fois arrêter ce
jeu par contre si les romains peuvent
les gens sont perdus train il affiche
est conforme à ce jour c'est la soupe à
quatre mois
c'est pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes coco
fob mais on adore la noix de coco
non pas du tout non coco termine bien